so Donald Trump delivered a completely
bizarre and self-congratulatory and very
deranged graduation speech at West Point
over the weekend it was riddled with
failed applause lines but most notably
at one point Donald Trump visibly
struggled to raise a glass of water to
his mouth and later struggled to walk
down a ramp almost having to be helped
down the ramp by a member of the
military now I'm going to show you the
video and we're going to talk about it
but this is as much a story about
right-wing hypocrisy as it is a story
about Donald Trump's cognitive and
physical state if Joe Biden did 20% of
what Trump did at this speech over the
weekend it would be a week of Fox News
and Oh a an adjective I'd and has
dementia with judge Jeanine bringing in
someone whose cousin's girlfriend once
went to medical school to say that Joe
Biden is unfit to lead if this was
Hillary it would be Hillary Parkinson's
times ten all over again and yet here
they are pretending like there's just
nothing to see here
other than so-called Trump derangement
syndrome and by the way Trump
derangement syndrome is a term that the
right has developed to not have to
address criticisms of Donald Trump you
say something about Trump you have Trump
derangement syndrome it's a way to stop
conversation so first of all at one
point during the speech Donald Trump
goes to drink water picks up a glass
with his right hand brings it about 80%
of the way to his lips his right hand
seemingly could go no higher
he tries moving his mouth down to bring
it down enough to get to the glass
couldn't do it and eventually uses his
left hand to very strangely pull the
glass towards his mouth and tilt it it
wasn't clear if the problem was with
Trump's right arm with his hand-eye
coordination we just have no idea but
this is not a normal way to drink water
and it's the second time at least that
we've seen Donald Trump bizarrely drink
water in this way then the other sort of
most notable moment during the speech
was Trump descending the ramp at the end
of the speech very gingerly carefully
like he was about to fall over very
strange and then he took a sort of hop
step at the bottom of the ramp which he
later described as jogging down the last
10 feet which we'll get to you'll also
notice that the officer Jeff
during gesturing for Trump to leave the
stage and then walking next to him
implies that the officer was briefed
ahead of time stay with Trump going down
the ramp so again we've seen Trump come
off of Air Force One sometimes with the
help of an aide we've seen various
versions of this he just doesn't look
stable when he's walking here so is this
the most important thing going on right
now it's not but again if this was Joe
Biden it would be a week on right-wing
media about how this proves Biden simply
cannot be President it's also aggravated
and becomes more interesting by Trump
immediately lying about it Trump
tweeting quote the RAM that I descended
after my West Point commencement speech
was very long and steep now it's not
very steep had no handrail and most
importantly was very slippery it was a
sunny day it was totally dry there's not
really any reason why it would be
slippery and people who were there said
it was not slippery and then Trump
saying the last thing I was going to do
is fall for the fake news to have fun
with final ten feet Iran took down to
ground level that's also a lie Trump
sort of took a two step hop he did not
run ten feet so it always attracts more
attention and his worse when Trump
starts lying about it there's also a
tweet for everything with Trump Trump
once criticized Barack Obama for how he
would walk out of Air Force One tweeting
in 2014 that quote Obama should stop
running down the stairs when getting off
Air Force One doesn't look presidential
and at some point he will take a fall
never happened and by the way we have
video of Barack Obama on the same ramp
that Trump was on Obama certainly
looking very very spry nothing to sneeze
at there so this is all very weird and
we don't really have an explanation
which I'll get back to the speech was
also filled with a ton of really other
weird moments Trump at one point
attempting to talk about former
president ulysses s grant he called him
you Lysias a couple of times didn't we
lead we need you to carry on the spirit
of the great General Ulysses Grant
that's weird then also struggling with
the name Douglas MacArthur seemingly
saying MacArthur MacArthur really just
multiple times we need you to be as bold
and determined as the immortal General
Douglas MacArthur who knew that the
American soldier never ever quits after
leaving the Philippines for Australia at
a low point of the Pacific War in 1942
MacArthur famously had I shall return
and then maybe the most cringe-worthy
moment was Trump's failed applause line
when he mentioned the two hundred and
forty fifth birthday of the army and
paused and looked around it was complete
crickets and then Trump decided to bring
up his own birthday I mean this is real
cringe tomorrow America will celebrate a
very important anniversary the two
hundred and forty fifth birthday of the
United States Army unrelated going to be
my birthday also I don't know if that
happened by accident did that happen by
accident please but it's a great day
because of that army birthday so a
absolutely embarrassing speech now as
far as the medical stuff Trump couldn't
lift a glass of water with his right arm
he seemed when he was walking down that
ramp that he was kind of favoring his
left side if someone wanted to speculate
about what's going on and that there
seems to be a left-right issue here you
would start thinking about stroke
remember that he was taken on short
notice to Walter Reed Hospital that time
they lied and said oh we decided to get
a jump on his 20/20 physical that was
back in 2019 totally not believable
you start to imagine because they don't
fill in the details maybe there's
something going on here that could be
stroke related now remember it's
speculative we don't know and the the
important thing to remember is if it
were Biden they would be saying this
video is proof that Biden should be
dropping out of the race really really
crazy stuff
c-calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy comm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for awhile now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman